let's start with an image one that
fascinated me for quite a while this is
the edge of the Rocky Mountains taken by
a satellite that's looking almost
horizontally rather than straight down
and it's a beautiful photo
but there's something weirder happening
to if we zoom in on the airport
notice that the runways that you see at
the top are perfectly parallel to each
other they're parallel to the highways
and the roads that we see as well and
they're parallel because there's no
perspective in this image and if we take
this perspective list image and stretch
it out vertically a little bit it starts
to look like something that's familiar
and quite important to me this is
SimCity 2000 arguably the best city
simulator ever made and it uses a very
similar perspective one that is in many
ways the same as Qbert or the same as
traditional painting in many cultures so
why don't most aerial photographs look
like Sim City screenshots and can we fix
that and what does it mean that we don't
see the world like this all the time
this is a talk about how light becomes
pixels why we see things like we do and
how we can use computers to knowingly
manipulate pixels such that we see the
world from new and unexpected angles to
begin what even is a camera let's say a
camera is anything that captures and
projects light like a digital camera or
eyes or a hole in the wall a camera
obscura this pinhole model of a camera
is simple but still very useful just
from the geometry here we can see that
moving objects closer and farther away
gives us images that are larger and
smaller and that's really all
perspective is the cows further down the
road aren't actually smaller cows they
just look that way so what would it take
to not have perspective would have to be
a situation where all of our projection
rays are parallel to each other this is
called an orthographic projection and
it's used in drafting and in simcity of
course to do this on a real camera you
need an image sensor the same size is
what you're trying to photograph which
is pretty
but in the computational world were less
limited so how can we do this
well let's notice something when objects
get farther away the angular difference
between this projection reins gets
smaller so if an object was very far
away the Rays would basically be
parallel if we restricted our field of
view to be very small so we magnify that
Center image now we can do this in most
3d rendering software pretty easily
for instance in matte box we just have
to change this one line that calculates
the matrix that turns a 3d coordinate
into a 2d coordinate and if we change
that field of view variable to make it
very small we get an orthographic render
and notice how now all of the avenues of
Manhattan are rendered perfectly
parallel to each other this is also a
great way to crash chrome you can do
this in Sim City in Google Earth as well
which starts to give some very sim citty
results but these are all just
simulations what can we do with images
captured by conventional cameras well a
kind of cool thing about cameras is that
every pixel in a camera is looking at
array in a slightly different direction
depending on where it is in the image so
if we take the same viewpoint looking
straight down but move it over the
camera around a little bit the angle
that we see things changes like this
building for example we can see it from
the south or from the north depending on
whether it's at the top or bottom of the
image so you can imagine a camera moving
looking down at a plane and as it moves
what it sees changes but it image --is
each part of the plane multiple times
from different directions so now imagine
we take all of those images and we just
take one row of rays from all of them
we take all those rows and we combine
them into one new image now we're
imaging a scene with rays that are
parallel to each other in one axis at
least and by taking different rows we
can change the angle of those parallel
rays so what does that look like well we
can take this input video and do exactly
that here we take the top row of every
frame what I want you to notice here is
that
looking at the south side of every
building whether the buildings at the
top of the image
or the bottom when we take the middle
row we're now looking straight down at
the street between the building but
notice that something else is happening
from left to right on the Left we see
the sunny side of each building and on
the right we see a shaded side so we
have an orthographic parallel projection
vertically but we still have our
perspective projection horizontally
because the Rays are only parallel in
one axis this is a kind of impossible
perspective something that we can only
do by synthesizing multiple viewpoints
and these are a lot like light fields so
talk to me later about how we can do fun
light field tricks like refocusing too
but sadly there's not enough time for
light fields when we use real camera
motion that's less perfect we can get
fun distortions with this technique and
when we use camera movement in other
axes like vertical from a drone takeoff
we get different effects but it's the
same technique and it's a simple
technique here's the pseudocode for all
those visualizations we loop through
every frame in a video grab a particular
row from each frame and put it in some
output image and that's it let's think
about what we're not doing
I love OpenCV but to make these we don't
need to do image analysis and find
correlations we just take pixels that
were in one place put them somewhere
else and let the geometry of image
formation do all of the hard work for us
so we've made some images more simcity
light but how can we generalize it one
way to think about this is to imagine a
video as a kind of flip book where we
stack up all of the frames on top of
each other and then imagine this flip
book as a volume that exists in the
space of XY and time so far we've been
taking slices in the XT plane out of
this volume but we could take slices in
arbitrary angles and directions I wrote
a program recently for exploring videos
like this here you can see it loading a
video as a volume and then displaying a
plane sliced through the image
what that looks like we can tilt it
around move it and explore what we can
find in these videos and I found a lot
of fun stuff for example the height of
buildings there three-dimensionality
rates are projection and causes them to
curve outward resulting in a kind of
vertigo movement in the z-axis seems to
curve distant scenes towards us
bending the earth and still camera
angles produce abstract patterns of
color that are broken by anything that
moves like cars or like Eddie's flowing
in a river so these are pretty pictures
but if there's some bigger reason to
care I think there is and I'll start
with some technical motivation remember
this image why didn't it have
perspective well it turns out that this
hybrid row-by-row imaging technique I've
been describing is exactly how
satellites image the world they use
exactly this where you have a scanner
moving across a scene next some more
philosophical consideration a lot of
what I've shown you today was developed
at signal culture a media art residency
upstate that evolved from the
experimental television center in 1969
working there I discovered the work of
stained 'va silca who used mirrors
distortion and technology to reconfigure
geographies of the American West to free
them from the tyranny of a single point
of view and to explore new ways of
seeing herself in the world I also
discovered Paul Ryan an artist she
perceived video accessibility as a tool
for evolutionary change and how we
interact with the world these artists
were working during a time of great
excitement and optimism about the
potential of new technologies to expand
perception and democratized culture
video and cinema were quickly moving
from resemblance to representation just
like painting and photography before
them had and today I think artistic use
of machine learning and virtual reality
may be reaching a parallel transition
the tradition of single viewpoint
perspective is just that a tradition
what would a world where photography
didn't have to emphasize and nearness
and the
'we looked like what would a world where
the foreground didn't overshadow the
background mean what if photographs were
cuts across time that simultaneously
showed the spatial and temporal
evolution of natural processes or what
if we could see land next to us and the
way it was being used as easily as we
could see clouds in the sky images of
the world affect the way that we think
about it and it's as important as ever
to remember that these images are not
reality itself they merely represent it
today's world is complicated and it
needs all of the perspectives it can get
I hope that machine learning satellite
photography video manipulation social
media analysis or whatever else it is
that you're into continues to help us
find new and critical ways of perceiving
the world and I hope that you leave
today and Bing Bank on this weekend with
some new ideas and inspiration about how
to do so thank you
[Applause]